a military display of prowess
and in amongst it men alongside women
[Music]
this was a celebration of military
equality
with the announcement that all roles
within the uk armed forces including
special forces are now open to women
when i train to be a gunner part of that
course is your armored fighting vehicle
recognition lance corporal kat dixon's
among the first females to qualify for
ground combat duties
i would say it takes a hell of a lot of
mental strength to be the only female in
a group of men
you have to have a lot of
self-confidence you have to believe in
yourself but i think to do this role
that is something
you need to have whether you're a man or
a woman
the defense secretary gavin williamson
made the announcement that ability not
gender will determine entry
but admitted more women still need to be
recruited into senior positions
we recognise that actually as the armed
forces do need to change and do need to
adapt and we're
quite willing to make those changes
either through legislation or the way
that we work because we
want uh women and men to succeed until
2016 females were restricted to
supportive
airborne duties or more defensive roles
on the ground
women have served on the front line like
this
for many years but the final barrier
being able to join
the uk special forces and do ground
close
combat roles has finally been lifted
and while the elite selection process
for the sas and royal marines will stay
the same for both sexes
some still feel females don't belong the
reality comes where there's also a right
for the soldiers who are fighting
to stay alive to live and we have to
look very carefully when
experts are telling politicians that
sometimes the operational capability and
the chances of survival
on the battlefield may be affected in
certain situations where you have a mix
of men and women
nevertheless brigadier sharon nesmith
says these changes mark a shift in
perception of women in the forces
i had to sign a piece of paper that said
should i have children that i would have
to leave the army
i was stood at the back of a parade you
know it's very different to
here i am 27 years later i've done
exactly the same as my male
contemporaries
commanded at every level and i've done
it all as a mum of two
this is clearly an evolving military
force
ripping up the old rulebook
bringing in the new adele robinson sky
news
salisbury plane